[Music]
it doesn't matter who you
are or which esport you play if you're
known for being
salty it's probably not a good thing
this king gave me [ __ ] if you're not
gonna participate
in the group activity then leave
don't mind me
like whether you're talking [ __ ] and
you're gonna want to wash the taste of
my out of your mouth
losing your [ __ ]
or desperately trying to keep your [ __ ]
intact
how could this happen to me
like to miss shots it often feels as if
competitive gaming is just
one big constant struggle to stay
composed but as with all rules there
exists
one exception and let me tell you this
one is real
salty just letting you know you're all
trash you're all [ __ ] awful dota
players
just accept it you're never going to be
good you have no hope you're wasting
your
life you should go to school and focus
on your studies it's not first time he
missed the stunt
all right dude let's drive over to his
house and beat the [ __ ] out of him
hey boyd stop hitting the [ __ ]
neutrals and use your chronosphere you
dumb piece of [ __ ]
meet peter ppd dagger dota 2's
resident all-american [ __ ] a cunning
strategist
and self-proclaimed salt lord whose
attitude allowed him to create
pretty much the greatest north american
superpower modern esports has ever seen
the problem is that depending on who you
ask that attitude
also unraveled it we're in the middle of
this huge divestment where we're all
taking ownership in eg
and it was oh and all of a sudden like
sumail didn't want to play with me
because i i'm a tough i'm a tough guy
i'm a strong personality and
when people aren't when i feel like
people aren't giving it they're all
that's that's when i you know that's my
biggest pet peeve that's when i actually
get frustrated
and in spite of all of his confidence
he's never been able to replicate that
success
so how did ppd's dickish demeanor both
pave his way to the top
and seemingly derail his career and more
importantly
can he ever get it back in your mind
what what makes a team successful
uh four really talented players plus me
i think
is a recipe for success
okay so if you're some little zoomer
who's unfamiliar with the great peter
pan damn and doesn't understand
how significant he was to the growth of
esports in na
you've got some catching up to do you
see dota's ever reigning salt lord
is just a good old midwestern boy who
likes his foosball almost as much as he
enjoys tearing people's hearts out
do you ever think that you would climb
all the way to the pinnacle of the dota
2 community and be on this panel
did you
[Applause]
but don't let his icy demeanor fool you
ppd isn't as cool as he might appear
so you thought jean-claude van damme
sounded cool and you said i gotta be a
little bit more like that so peter pan
damn yeah and then i shortened it to pvd
when i came to dota because i needed a
cool three-letter name like everybody
else
anyway like a lot of dota grades ppd got
his start in heroes of new earth but as
soon as he got his hands on valve's much
anticipated dota 2
he became a god at it and it wasn't long
before he'd cemented himself as one of
the game's most
galaxy brain strategists the damage has
been done
and there it is wow empire will tap out
ppd has drafted really well for this
team
uh for the past week right now i dare i
say it we haven't seen navier lines play
this patch yet
but so far he may be the you may have
be the strongest drafter in the left or
in the west or at least he's drafting
the strongest correctly
see even though ppd didn't boast
especially great mechanics
it didn't matter he was a thinker a
shot caller a brazen bully who led his
teammates to victory through
air-tight drafts and an unerring sense
of confidence
if he watches replays of all the teams
we're about to play
studies up on what we should be picking
theorycraft strats we can be playing as
well
we have no one to lead us if it wasn't
for happening the flip side is that he
was a sacrificial support
the kind who was so fixated on enabling
his teammates that he forwent
pretty much all forms of farm in fact
the fifth position playstyle that ppd
pioneered was
so impoverished that the community
coined it position
six my individual skill set that i was
best at was just my positioning
and in team fights i just kind of you
know if you put yourself in a really
good position you don't necessarily need
the fastest reaction time
you know all those things that you know
maybe people thought that i was lacking
people can talk smack and say i'm like
you know low mechanical skill and all
that stuff you know but uh i'm a lot
better than
you know people give me credit for it at
a time when north american dota had yet
to be taken seriously
ppd spearheaded the explosive sad boys
roster who were quickly signed by evil
geniuses
and he led them straight to the top
within a year of going pro
he managed a top three finish at ti4 the
mason's already triggered off the old
man in range of the tower there's your
boy we got hexed the second he jumped in
they can kill him off the global star's
burning he bk beats chronos but he's
already dead
prophet kills him off eyesight side is
trapped outside
mmy he tries to go on universe but he
just gets obliterated three heroes down
the top ranks will go as well and that's
gg
eating it through the winners bracket
final
so how exactly did ppd turn a group of
misfits
into a superpower well by being a
dictator
by making it absolutely clear that it
was his way
or the god damn highway it's hard to get
people to commit to things to commit to
ideas
he's somebody that forced people to
commit to doing things he would commit
himself
by putting himself out there first and
that was something that the scene had
lacked for a very long time and because
the man was a veritable genius of the
game
pbd's tyranny yielded results
if they can't kill that creep they're in
too much trouble
simba dropping now he's out of the fight
and it's on to the throne
the boys in blue in kiev they got secret
by the jugular
and they take home the grand finals they
are the starladder season 10 champions
i made so many sacrifices part of what i
do is because
i like to compete being able to say that
i
competed and pushed myself to a limit
you know where not everyone else can get
to
is very rewarding the problem of course
is that when you're
so used to being right it can be pretty
frustrating to watch
others be wrong ppd was the kind of
competitor who expected
the best of not only himself but
everyone around him
and let's just say he wasn't shy about
it
sunstrike my mate
oh my god
no [ __ ] you suck for sure dude are you
nice or naughty
these days i'm actually really really
mannered right now i think
it's uh it's a new thing i'm trying my
mmr went up like 400 in like two days
so nice you know kill him with kindness
that's what i say hey dumbass [ __ ]
willow buy some [ __ ] sentries you
useless piece of [ __ ]
ppd loved trash talk and had zero
tolerance for incompetence
and whether through biting sarcasm or
blatant barbaric abuse
he made a point of showing it alright so
in order at the very beginning of the
game
you're going to want to open with
insulting the team's draft
obviously they probably had a little bit
of debate about it and they're making
some team choices and
maybe that somebody was a little edge on
edge on a couple of those so you just
try and reaffirm those uh
negative opinions and really start the
negativity for the other team
at minute zero hey don't give up you're
playing great you can
come back and be a huge part of this
victory
[Music]
before long ppd had cemented himself as
the saltiest son of a [ __ ] dota had
ever seen
and the community loved him for it he
actually got like a portrait that's made
out of salt
now unfortunately for ppd not everybody
responds particularly well to that kind
of
despotic leadership he's had to learn
some
you know hard lessons in the last couple
years
and i think he's also changed as a
person and as a captain
i would say the lowest point was like
right when artesians i left
especially zai like that was someone i'd
been playing with for a significant
amount of time that i thought like
really like believed in me and trusted
me i had like feelings of being betrayed
and that that sucks but as it turns out
that was
pretty much the best thing that could
have happened to him i went around and
talked to players about joining our team
and everyone nobody wanted to play with
us
everyone thought that we were on the
losing end of this western shuffle
see while everyone else was off building
super teams ppd
took his scrappy sumail and aoi centric
iteration of eg
and instilled within them the one thing
the previous roster had
never really had trust and
at ti5 ppd would lead this new look eg
all the way to the grand finals where
they would go on
to make history there is no hook shot
they're all together ppd here comes the
ice blast ready for the
[Applause]
universe is ready to turn he's got equal
slam up he just sees this bling they're
going to come back and call it
aggressive the call down the perfect
position
aggressive locked in position right now
he could embrace stop by the window
but fear moving forward as well the dk
[Applause]
champions from there on out ppd's status
as the best drafter in the world
was absolute he'd led a grassroots group
of
actual north americans to the biggest
championship in
esports and proven that even with a
so-called
second-hand roster he could outwit
anyone
following their ti triumph ppd stock
only grew
he'd reached the apex of tier one play
and was willing to do whatever it took
to stay there
we ended up releasing aui and bringing
in our old teammate artesi
to play with us and
um it's just kind of what everyone on
our team thought was best for us
but it wasn't long after eg saw the
return of their prodigal son
that arteezy and ppd once again began to
clash
of course this time around ppd had a ti
to his name
so his rule became all but absolute and
despite having the best roster in the
world on paper
this tension within the team caused them
to flounder
ultimately resulting in artesi's second
departure
the second one was [ __ ] to be honest
it was really
stupid i was very very upset i was
pissed that kind of change was very
unwarranted and like i said before it
was definitely like players were giving
up
here's the crazy thing though for the
second year in a row eg
entered the international with a cobbled
together lineup
and for the third year in a row they
achieved a
top three finish it was uncanny as
soon as ppd and his compatriots were
counted out
that's when they'd come alive and he's
trying to get ppd but evil genius is
cool calm and collected
they're holding the defense here again
[Applause]
down one by back and that's only the
warlock it's only mega creeps and
warlock who could defend this
evil geniuses have they just done it
that was a hold of a lifetime eeg
this team just does not win 60 seconds
without this jug e home can they hold
eg confident they can't smears coming up
as well
the tier four is being beat not in the
game the jump forward
somehow already going out of bedroom no
chaotic offerings first
[Applause]
it's over
the impossible comeback made possible
by eot i can safely say i've never seen
something like that
after ti eg decided to reclaim artesi
for a
third time and the question was whether
he and his captain would finally be able
to put aside their differences
of course they never got their chance
since artesi wasn't the only superstar
who thought that ppd was hard to work
with
he was the player who played the least
pubs on the team
who practices the least on the team who
would tilt out
after every scrim every tournament like
if you lose a scream he would just put
his headsets on and you know sign off
it turned out that the very roster the
ppd had skyrocketed to success
had finally had enough of his [ __ ]
though it wasn't made public until later
ppd didn't so much step down from evil
geniuses
as much as he was kicked you know we had
to talk after ti and it was
hey what are we gonna do we're in the
middle of this huge divestment where
we're all taking ownership in eg
and it was oh and all of a sudden like
sumail didn't want to play with me
because i i'm a tough i'm a tough guy
i'm a strong personality and
when people aren't when i feel like
people aren't giving it they're all
that's that's when i you know that's my
biggest pet peeve that's when i actually
get frustrated
and that kids is how peter dagger became
a professional
gwent player who's going to move on to
the finals will be noxious
or ppd
anyway leaving aside his weird foray
into the witcher-based card game
what ppd really went on to do was become
the ceo of the very org that ousted him
after ti6 the plan was not for me to be
the ceo
that was not the initial plan it just
kind of changed into that
now in some weird way it kind of made
sense
ppd was certainly a very smart dude he
seems to have a mind for business
and it felt from the outside as if he'd
achieved everything he'd set out to do
as a competitor listen if all else fails
you might need to make a new team what
happened to eeg
well you own eg now makes sense
so where are you now i'm at ti7
how do we do in groups eg is doing well
but
you're not playing you're working main
stage panel you're working main stage
panel
panel but as much as ppd had already
proven himself to be the greatest leader
that na had ever had
he still had a competitive itch that
needed to be scratched so
he joined optic gaming in the hope of
achieving
yet another ti success so i went to ti7
as a commentator and i had
the idea of playing in the upcoming
season it was too exciting to watch and
not participate
so i just built the best team possible
that i could and i was
lucky and fortunate enough to find three
of these guys
the problem is that despite finding
players willing to fall into line
ppd wasn't able to recapture the magic
he was able to produce with eg
not long after optic imploded ppd tried
his luck again with ninjas in pajamas
but once again he failed to relive his
past successes with a new roster
and finally in april of 2020 the salt
king
announced his retirement i'm pretty
passionate about helping esport players
build
futures for themselves and that's what i
really really want to help with
i think it's more likely going to end up
in sort of some sort of like influencer
management role
where i can help ideally i help esport
players become better content creators
so they can build their brands alongside
their careers that way they have options
when they decide to stop
uh competing i'm excited to see if i can
uh bring my philosophy somewhere and
actually make some change
and that's and that's really hard to do
as a dota player ultimately
it isn't clear why ppd fizzled out
whether he was a victim of circumstance
his own uncontrollable ego or a little
bit of both
what is clear is that he remains to this
day both
the single most important north american
competitor to touch dota
and one of the most dominant drafters of
all time
whatever you think of ppd it's
undeniable
that his brash brazen attitude helped
put
his region on the map he's proof
that sometimes to be successful you have
to make
unpopular decisions that will make
people despise
you there are a lot of north american
superstars who
talk big when it comes to bodying other
regions some with moderate success
but in the whole of modern esports
there's only been
one who's been able to do it
consistently
and that's ppd i've been saying bad
things right but i i would say i'll also
say this i have no doubt in her mind
that peter was the best captain like
in the history of dota during like tier
5 era like
he was really good at what he did he had
really good ideas he
he was like super confident he he knew
how to run players around
he took a group of ragtag n a [ __ ]
that
no one took seriously gave them a sense
of direction
and watched as they flourished into the
region's greatest
ever dota team while these days his
sights might be set on
arcade cs go it's not entirely clear if
na's
sodium-borne savior is truly done
chasing another aegis
but chances are whether it's with
respect to winning
or whining we've yet to hear the last of
ppd
there will be screaming yes guys i will
be screaming at my teammates at some
point tonight
this is just a little bit of a precursor
a little bit of a warning before
i totally go off the rails dude you just
like suck at mid i don't know what to
say
i need help with the heels like you
can't solo heal it
i know i'm being serious right now i
heal 20k more than every other healer
dude nice job man keep it up
it's not about nice job keeping up i
need i need help
yeah [ __ ] muted shut the [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
one of the things that separates eg that
dynasty bg from so many
north american esports teams is that n a
esports is always like
you know three european players and like
maybe two guys from north america right
if not all europeans like
today right now there is there are no
americans on evil geniuses there's one
canadian
and four like people from from europe
from
various european countries from uh
israel like there's there's no actual
n a player save one